hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Doctor Who episode 6 video Maisie
Williams part 2 it was kind of a
continuation of last week's story
although it was kind of like its own
self-contained story it's just like a
bookend for her on the show I felt like
there was a really good chance after
last week's episode that she could be a
potential new companion but there were
some interesting things that the doctor
said like some interesting speeches he
had in this episode that changed the way
I felt about that so we can we can talk
about it as we get into spoilers just
careful if you haven't seen the episode
yet a new round of the Doctor Who
giveaway starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video starting with
number 5 Maisie Williams is the
nightmare child and she and the doctor
both tried to rob the same carriage
without realizing it who else thought of
the nightmare child from the end of time
like the David Tennant shout out clearly
Russell T Davies had no idea that Maisie
Williams would be cast on the show
someday but I like the way Moffat can
now like weave Maisie Williams character
into Doctor Who history just because she
is functionally immortal even though the
last speech the doctor had with her was
rather hopeful the ambiguous end tag
leaves it open to just about anything
you could imagine
but I really like the energy in this
opening scene just the comedy of the
doctor robbing the stagecoach and then
not realising that someone else was
robbing at the same time I do believe
there's a robbery happening right now
sometimes it's hard to tell when the
doctor just doesn't care enough to pay
attention to what's going on around him
and when he's purposefully acting stupid
but on a number for the shielder
explains what's happened to her in the
last 800 years and the doctor reads her
journals so all very sad things but she
does mention a really cool historical
event that Game of Thrones also borrows
a little bit from George our Martin just
takes from real-world history when he's
writing Game of Thrones like the War of
the Roses or the Hundred Years War and
that's what Maisie Williams mentioned in
this episode the shielder kind of took
responsibility for ending the war you
could think of her as being the Joan of
Arc figure and that just because Joan of
Arc was a big figure during the Hundred
Years War he fired 10,000 arrows you're
an expert I don't need to be immortal
I'm just really awesome but then you get
the comedy death montage where like
everybody tries to kill her for helping
people she's a witch drown her that
actually is probably what would happen
the the sad part though is as the
doctors reading her journals is just the
sorrow she feels as the people she loves
die
and yes she did have actual children
like she did give birth to children
that's what these are for I will endure
but no more children that event in
particular was during the plague and
when the doctors telling her about
things coming like you know big big
things that are gonna be crazy in the
future that she'll run into he mentions
the ter leptons and the Great Fire of
London the doctor ended up running into
the terrell up those in like 1666 that's
also the same year that the Great Fire
of London happened so he can name drop
really really just about anything from
Doctor Who the history that she would
potentially run into in the future girl
in the fireplace it really just depends
on where is shielder lives in the world
on the number three the doctor and his
shield er versus Sam Smyth and his band
of robbers this is mostly done for
comedy but there was a huge doctor's
daughter shout out I'm surprised I
didn't see more Jenny jokes on Twitter
when the episode was happening just
because Sam was making fun of the doctor
for being so old but you brought your
father with you no not the puns no
banter turns out the doctor really
doesn't like puns of course she is not
the actual doctors daughter but so many
people thought that she might be after
she was announced for the show that I
feel like they might have written this
in just to poke fun at that on to number
two
meet Leandro from Delta Leona's who has
tricked his shielder into getting his
amulet the eye of Hades back so that he
can open a portal for his people I'm
kind of wondering if the show's gonna
bring them back or Maisie Williams just
because the titles of the finale are
heaven sent in hell-bent in this episode
was all about opening a portal possibly
to hell there was a lot of verbal
wordplay about going to other planes of
existence in hell but presumably they
destroyed this amulet or the doctor
rendered it inert after they save Sam
Smythe using the other chip so the
finale titles could be a complete
coincidence I think it has something to
do with Gallifrey but it could also have
more to do with Maisie Williams
character in the Delta Leona's the
gallows humor was kind of funny
I did feel Maisie Williams emotional arc
in the episode it was all about her like
slowly kind of turning into a Time Lord
type personally someone who just didn't
care about humanity that much like how
immortality kind of drains that out of
you that's that's why the doctor is so
special because he still does have
empathy you could make a lot of Time
Lord references to Maisie Williams
character but Time Lords act a little
more superior she was just kind of burnt
out on earth she's just like I'm bored I
want out of here
I want something exciting I want to feel
something again but finally on to my
number one WTF moment
the shielder is going to keep her eyes
on the doctor and she shows up in one of
Cara's photos in present day so
regardless of what you think about the
emotional arc in the episode with
whether or not it landed with you or you
like the other characters I feel like
they ended things on a really good note
it just very very ambiguous and that
Maisie Williams can totally come back
but they could also just kind of write
her off into the distance I think a lot
of it just depends on scheduling and
contracts and stuff like that but the
energy between her and the doctor is
really interesting because she's like
it's your friends you need to watch out
for so if you want to take it as like
like a hopeful moment you could draw
parallels to the impossible girl's
storyline where Clara like all over time
and space car just tries to save the
doctor from certain situations I try to
help him out whenever she can but in the
case of a shield ER it makes it sound
like she's doing that from the
background like less than an obvious way
than Clara did it like I'm standing here
in the background just keeping an eye on
things making sure everything's okay but
just to talk about Maisie Williams
potentially being the next companion I
felt like that final scene with the
doctor threw a lot of water on that
theory just in being that the doctor was
saying people like us need to surround
ourselves with normal people so that
they don't lose their connection to
humanity so I felt like that's the show
like the writers and Moffat just saying
that no Maisie Williams isn't gonna be
the next companion but she will come
back because she's immortal she'll be
like Captain Jack who also got a big big
shout out in that speech her shield her
spent the whole episode just like
throwing in the doctors face I'm waiting
for you to take you with me why don't
you take you with me and he says because
it won't end well if you ever forget how
things like that end just look at the
face of BOE pora Captain Jack but if
they were able to leech jack's
immortality out during Torchwood then
I'm supposing you could think that it's
possible for a shield ER to die too she
says that in the episode - like
hopefully he'll kill me quickly but you
always do kind of wonder like because
when you see the face of BOE you're like
well clearly he has his immortality back
so he doesn't end up dying those are
just inconsistencies in the timeline
that future showrunners will have to
step around but let me know what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and like after just after watching that
final speech with the doctor and the end
tag with Maisie Williams do you think
that she has a chance of being the next
companion or do you think that that
whole speech was about her not being the
next companion I loved her in the
episode like I loved Maisie Williams and
Doctor Who
it's an interesting character that you
could weave into Doctor Who in a bigger
way if she ever does want to come back I
almost feel like she's a little too
famous to be the companion usually they
pick someone that's a little bit more of
an up-and-comer and she's just kind of
already relatively well-established
thanks to Game of Thrones and some of
the film work that she's done
as for the spin-off series I would say
that she's also fair game to show up on
that too but that feels like it's gonna
be smaller than the main show so I'm not
expecting to see her on that like that
Monster Hunter spin-off that they're
developing so there any other Easter
eggs in the episode that you saw that I
didn't mention like you know Hundred
Years War doctor's daughter Tara leptons
just be sure to add them in the comments
below next week's episode is like the
beginning of the Zygon episode I believe
that's also a two-parter and it's the
return of Osgood I think we're feeling
like it might be Zygon Osgood because
they're billing it as a Zygon revolution
so like something is going on in saigon
culture on earth congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner
Beowulf adren or you win a $20 Amazon
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I get
your contact info so what I'm gonna do
next is is tonight I'm gonna try and get
my Gotham video out tomorrow will be
relatively normal just you know Game of
Thrones Walking Dead later that night so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
we can debate the future amazing
Williams in the comments really hope
that she comes back soon small chance
that she might even show up before the
end of the year but I feel like this was
kind of intended to be a bookend to her
time on Doctor Who this episode in
particular just in case you haven't seen
it in related Doctor Who news David
Tennant in the Jessica Jones trailer you
can click here to watch that he is super
creeptastic and you can click here for
the Star Wars Episode 7 trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five see you guys tonight